i do not think we can carry on with
business as usual that is why we need to
be bold bold bold and we need to do
things differently
big promises a grand vision and a new
prime minister setting out a new
direction for the economy but what does
trusonomics as some have called it
actually involve
perhaps the best person to ask is this
man gerard lyons he's been informally
advising the trust team
i think the first thing is that she will
confront the immediate challenge in
terms of the energy crisis but trust
economics is more than that it's about
having a pro-growth economic strategy
built on really the three arrows arrows
of monetary policy that keeps inflation
in check
fiscal policy that stabilizes the
economy and a supply-side agenda very
much focused on boosting investment
and getting the incentives right that's
low taxes and smart regulation
now in some senses none of this is very
new every government wants economic
growth the problem is well making it
happen especially in the face of
challenging times
it's hard to think of another prime
ministership that has begun with the uk
facing quite so much economic jeopardy
energy prices at a record high the
pounder of record low the uk facing a
potential recession these are all what
you might call red flashing lights so
for all the talk about trustanomics the
chances are her tenancy and indeed her
chancellors could well be defined
instead by what harold macmillan called
event steerboy events
now even before you consider her energy
program liz trust had already promised a
host of spending increases to the extent
that experts are struggling to keep up
we know that beyond supporting energy
bills it seems to me inconceivable that
they won't be finding additional money
for public services so there's a lot of
extra money going to be needed there
which we haven't heard anything about
that's tens of billions that's tens of
billions and in addition um of course
we've heard promises of tens of billions
of tax cuts or at least intended tax
increases not going to
happen 100 billion or more on energy
further sums on spending and on tax cuts
you've probably already noticed a
pattern about trust anomics it's quite
expensive
so where's that money going to come from
trust will actually say borrowing is not
a constraint
bahrain is an option at the moment we
need to have fiscal discipline we need
to have financial support just borrow as
much as you want no it's about having
censored there
it's not borrowing as much as you want
it's about having a sense of economic
policy still it all points to higher
debt and the more debt they're racking
up over there in westminster the higher
all our sequel interest rates will go so
this place the bank of england becomes
all important as does
the wider city because if you are
borrowing money then you really need to
find someone to lend it to you
that in the end was why george osborne
and rishi sunak didn't do things like
this
if trustonomics works it could mean we
get through the current crisis and maybe
even get better off
if not well it could be a bumpy few
years
ed conway sky news